[Musique]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 29 mai le 7-8
journal de tv 78 pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale tout de suite lé
titre de cette édition mille élèves de
la maternelle à la seconde sur la scène
du prix smile en cours le quatrième
challenge ski robe s'est tenue lundi à
mardi le principe pour ces jeunes
programmé un petit robot et réussir à
franchir un parcours sur le thème cette
année du cinéma c'est un dîner annuel
organisé par le collectif des
associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de ses
environs de came 78 a réuni hier à
coignières représentants de l'état des
pouvoirs publics et des autres
confessions religieuses du département
un moment de partage en ce mois du
ramadan et elle est l'une des plus
anciennes radios libres de france hervé
vs pour radio vexin val de seine fête
cette année ses 40 ans une histoire
débutée en 1979 avec une émission
piratés qui se poursuit aujourd'hui sous
la forme associative son président
jean-françois de nager notre invité et
puis la présentation est également tout
à l'heure en plateau du rallye
motocycliste organisé ce dimanche par la
gendarmerie des yvelines
quelques jours après le scrutin des
élections européennes
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fêtait lieu
pour la deuxième fois l'agglomération
organisait son joli mois de l'europe
c'était aujourd'hui au centre commercial
espace saint quentin
l'objectif expliqué au public l'action
concrète de l'union européenne sur le
territoire et les fonds perçus en
qualité de territoire dit i té i saint
quentin en yvelines bénéficie par
exemple d'une enveloppe de 5,2 millions
d'euros pour financer des projets est
notamment de rénovation thermique ou
pour lutter contre la fracture numérique
elle les propos sont recueillis par
nicolas kirillovitch souvent les
citoyens sont
peu informés des actions qui sont menées
par l'europe sont financés par l'europe
et notamment dans le cadre
une grosse part des fonds européens du
fonds social européen sur le territoire
qui est consacré au retour à l'emploi
des
des demandeurs d'emploi les publics
fragilisés donc
voilà c'est important que
que le grand public soit au courant de
ces aspects là et on parlera europe plus
particulièrement des élections
européennes qui ont livré leur verdict
dimanche c'est tout à l'heure sur tv 78
dans l'émission en 7 8 débat présenté
par aurélie rose
clap de fin pour la quatrième édition du
challenge ski robe durant deux jours
mille élèves du territoire se sont
affrontés sur la scène du prisme à
elancourt leur mission bien programmé un
petit robot pour qu'il réussisse à
boucler un parcours c'est un projet
porté par l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et l'éducation
nationale les précisions d'aurélien aux
explosions de joie pour ces classes de
cm1 et cm2 de l'école de la nouvelle
amsterdam à elancourt
ils viennent de terminer premiers de
leur groupe ils se sont préparés toute
l'année pour cette quatrième édition du
challenge robotique à skis rob owen a
fait tomber avant chez owens la lumière
du jour et on a travaillé dur pour fait
pour faire sont les robes on les a bien
calibrée
tout s'est très bien déroulé pendant
deux jours mille élèves de la maternelle
à la seconde se sont affrontés sur la
scène du prix sema et long cours
le principe faire évoluer un petit robot
sur un parcours semé d'obstacles thème
retenu cette année robotique et cinéma
pour récolter un maximum de points il
fallait arriver jusqu'au trophée entre
ça intéressant parce que ça nous faisait
travailler dans plusieurs domaines
notamment au niveau des mathématiques
mais aussi au niveau du français sur la
rédaction des textes les mises en scène
aussi filmé et beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup dans le repérage dans l'espace
organisé par saint quentin en yvelines
et l'éducation nationale ce rendez vous
annuel permet de mettre en avant
l'enseignement du codage à l'école 80%
des emplois demain seront liés au
numérique donc il faut vraiment mais sur
un milliard et de culture numérique
l'implication plus des enfants
extraordinaires de vous voyez qu'ils
sont heureux ils sont ils prennent du
plaisir à prendre
chaque année on se rend compte qu'on
n'embarque de plus en plus de classes de
plus en plus d'établissements et les
partenaires sont toujours très réactifs
pour nous accompagner sur ce projet
chaque apprenti codeurs a été récompensé
pour son investissement est d'ici 2020
100 % des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines pourront être équipés d'outils
numériques
une signature pour transformer le
quartier de la noé à
chanteloup-les-vignes c'est chose faite
entre le département la communauté
urbaine de grand paris seine et oise et
la municipalité
hier mardi ces trois acteurs ont signé
la convention priori blinn pour une
rénovation urbaine d'importance
le département participe à hauteur de
18,5 millions d'euros principalement
pour la création d'une cité éducative de
nouveaux programmes de logements la
construction aussi d'une maison à
médical et un réaménagement de l'entrée
de la ville
une première convention qui pourrait en
amener d'autres écouter ses propos au
micro d'yves hub stand berger près de
50%
de la dépense est porté par le
département qui fait de la lutte contre
les inégalités territoriales un de ses
combats phare et nous investirons en
particulier sur la période 2010 8 2024
donc sur un plan de six ans nous
investirons 700 millions d'euros dans
l'ensemble des sites de la politique de
la ville dans les yeux on a le devoir de
décloisonner l'éducation nationale le
temps de l'enfant ça n'est pas que le
temps de l'école le temps de l'enfance
et le temps de la rue le temps auprès
des parents le temps du père éducatif et
le temps de l'école et cynthia si on
porte pas un projet fort et ce projet
fort il a besoin de bâti il a besoin de
vivre ensemble il a besoin que les
acteurs vivent ensemble donc en même
temps il ya un projet éducatif fort
savez la cité éducative et puis il ya un
projet bâti fort qui s'appelle le pria
la direction à présent coignières
toujours hier mardi le collectif des
associations musulmanes de saint quentin
en yvelines et de ses environs
organisait son traditionnel dîner annuel
il réunit en plein mois du ramadan tous
les responsables religieux et politiques
du territoire autour d'un repas
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
des juifs des musulmans des chrétiens
les communautés religieuses ont répondu
à l'invitation lancée par le cames 78 le
collectif des associations musulmanes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de ses
environs organisait son quatrième dîner
annuel en plein ramadan le rendez-vous a
débuté par les discours objectif montrer
la cohésion entre les représentants des
différents cultes du territoire il ya
toujours besoin de rappel et pas d'eau
rappelle nécessairement aux personnes de
cette assemblée la mais peut-être le
rappelle qu'il faut que l'on soit tous
vigilants ensemble face à une ambiance
qui n'est peut-être pas des meilleures
un climat qui peut quelquefois être
anxiogène c'est une opportunité de
dialogue et de fraternité
et je crois que au jour le jour la paix
sociale se construit comme ça par la
connaissance réciproque et le dialogue
ensemble je crois que nous sommes sur la
bonne voie pour donner exemple à la
jeunesse
du quoi exemple de rapports harmonieux
dans la salle et sur la scène des
personnalités politiques du département
des maires de toute étiquette le
président du département pierre bédier
le préfet jean-jacques brot ou encore
des députés je crois que le fait qu'on
soit là en tant que parlementaire en
tant que représentant de l'état s'est
démontré que la concorde républicaine
c'est d'arriver justement à ce que
ensemble dans une même salle quelles que
soient nos convictions religieuses qu'on
aime qu'on en ait pas on est en capacité
ensemble de faire nation et ça c'est ce
que nous permet dalaï cité où je pense
que être présent c'est finalement porter
notre témoignage à sare la soirée s'est
terminée par une rupture du jeûne du
ramadan entre les 100 invités présents
laurent des bouts d'os est à nouveau
être organisées l'année prochaine par le
cames 78 en tant que média local nous ne
pouvions passer à côté de cet
anniversaire hervé vs à 40 ans radio
vexin val de seine basé aux mureaux va
soufflé sa bougie le samedi 15 juin à
l'antenne sur l'antenne mais également
aux pôles molière de la ville on va
présenter le programme avec vous jean
françois delage bonsoir bonsoir d'être
le président de rbs qui émet aujourd'hui
sur la fréquence 96 points de 40 ans
pour votre radio ça signifie quoi quelle
est l'importance de cet anniversaire est
bien la pérennité surtout de la
pérennité
les difficultés vous savez la radio
associative pour pouvoir durer
ce n'est pas évident puisque
financièrement nous ce n'est pas évident
parce que financièrement pour budgétiser
l'année avec toutes les installations
techniques le suivi et puis la
maintenance eh bien il faut des
financements et pour ses financements
parce que qui dit côté associatif
forcément on vit des subventions aussi
la radio département tout à fait du
département de la région et puis de la
municipalité
alors nous sommes situés aux mureaux les
je tiens à préciser aussi que nous avons
un relais sur issou donc l'émetteur et
aïssou la ville d'izu que je remercie au
passage et les 40 ans de radio vexin val
de seine et bien c'est un grand moment
parce que la radio a débuté en 79 radio
pirate c'est ça c'était une première
émission pirates le 10 juillet le 18
juin 1979 on rappelle le contexte à
l'époque il fallait avoir une
autorisation
bien sûr administrative 1 celle qui est
encore aujourd'hui pour émettre et il y
avait de nombreux radio pirate c'est un
mouvement qui vient du nord de l'europe
s'était aussi présent en france ce
mouvement des radios pirates
oui tout à fait tout à fait présent
france alors c'est une bande de copains
et qui ont eu cette idée donc délocalisé
quelquefois dans la forêt landais dans
des bâtiments
et puis en 80 donc les radios libres ont
eu le droit de démettre
et bien justement
radio avec ça en a profité pour créer
l'association ac vs association pour la
communication dans la vallée de la seine
et donc radieux vexin val de seine a
demandé des fréquences qu'elle a obtenu
la première fréquence justement à
l'époque était le 108 points 500 points
8 pardon oui ça a changé au cours de
l'histoire de la radio 100 points 2 et
ensuite 96 x 2 fm
donc c'est la fréquence actuelle et vous
parlez de radios libres c'est un statut
qui a été créé je crois que c'était sous
la présidence de françois mitterrand
c'est dans cet esprit aujourd'hui radios
libres c'est toujours une marque
d'identité pour hervé vs c'est important
de montrer que qui a rêvé c'est une
radio libre la liberté de parole voilà
donc c'est une radio pluriculturelle
nous avons des émissions justement
communautaire émission italienne
émission yougoslave et à des portugais
eux aussi qui ont leurs émissions donc
voilà l'échec identité à la parole on
passe toute la culture européenne
africaine et c'est ce qui est justement
l'impact de l'impact dans notre radio
sur la ville des mureaux et sur d'autres
vivent 1 les identitaires se retrouvent
et bien sûr on n'oublie pas la musique
française qui est un qui est là avec eux
avec aussi du métal je salue d'ailleurs
l'équipe qui le rôle de nous au passage
parce que c'est une émission qui est
très écouté sur sur notre radio
vous parliez tout à l'heure des
difficultés à être aujourd'hui une radio
associative du fait des subventions
pourquoi il faut absolument aujourd'hui
défendre ce statut face à des radios
privées pourquoi la radio associative a
toute sa place dans le paysage
radiophonique français
et bien parce que si c'est ce feu ce
droit de parole cette liberté cette
liberté de donc de parole en respectant
bien sûr d'une institution c'est tout à
fait normal et nous sommes des bénévoles
nous sommes quarante bénévoles pour
cette radio une salariée qui est notre
secrétaire et ses quarante bénévoles
donnent de leur temps
nous avons des retraités nous avons des
personnes qui sont encore en activité et
qui donnent de leur temps pour des
réunions pour aussi entretenir la radio
les locaux bien sûr parce que c'est de
l'entretien à faire de la peinture et
refaire les studios nous avons une
personne qui est chargé toute la partie
informatique qui est aussi bénévole et
et tout cela est bien sans ses bénévoles
la radio ne pourrait plus exister et
notre époque et aujourd'hui vous avez
vous arrivez encore à attirer ces
bénévoles ou c'est plus compliqué c'est
plus compliqué ya moins de deux moins de
d'élan que kylie à 25 ou 30 ans on
assite justement les jeunes puisque
notre radio est en partenariat avec
certaines écoles pour des ateliers radio
pour inciter les jeunes à venir faire
des émissions créer des émissions mais
le fait d'être bénévole maintenant
n'attire plus grande on va lui dire et
vous le disais tout à l'heure
dont 40 bénévoles une salariée etc des
émissions vraiment sur plusieurs thèmes
notamment la musique vous parliez de la
musique italienne enfin voilà il ya
plusieurs thèmes que l'on peut trouver à
l'antenne mais commissaire thème tout à
fait plusieurs thèmes et d'ailleurs
j'invite un surprofit j'invite à aubes
les personnes qui souhaiteraient créer
aucune émission ce soir culturel une
émission littéraire et bien je vous
invite à nous contacter sur hervé vs et
c'est qui s'affiche actuellement oui rbs
et donc allons nous étudions les projets
nous demandons toujours une maquette
le conseil d'administration qui se
réunit tous les mois décide si
l'émission rentre bien dans notre dans
notre éthique pour justement l'accepter
ou la refuser mais moi j'ai toujours un
dialogue refuse refuse rarement on
pourra découvrir redécouvrir la radio
lors de son anniversaire ce sera donc le
samedi 15 juin quel est le programme de
cette journée
je crois que c'est autour de la musique
et de la danse se serait alors la
matinée est consacrée donc à partir de
11h au protocole avec les autorités qui
sont invités les anciens animateurs
savoir que laurent romejko est passé
soit on meurt à dioïla des beatles et
autres radios et c'est une référence
aussi pour pour nous et puis d'autres
qui sont allés sur d'autres d'autres
médias donc le 15 juin c'est la partie
protocole de 11h à 13h souffler les
bougies des 40 ans et ensuite à l'espace
molière des murs aux tables rondes et
des spectacles
dans ce champ jusqu'à jusqu'à 23 on
retrouve tout programme bien sûr sur le
site d'air vvs on vous souhaite quoi
pour vos quarante ans encore dans la
pérennité et beaucoup beaucoup de bonnes
choses et puis n'hésitez pas à venir un
venir nous voir et puis à venir aussi
proposer des émissions les pions on peut
vous souhaiter d un bon anniversaire
merci jean françois delage d'ailleurs
passé sur ce plateau président de rbs
qui a donc quarante ans après un an de
travaux la place saint-pierre et le parc
du château de plaisir ont retrouvé les
beautés de leur jeunesse le tout a été
inaugurée vendredi et 24 mai est
marylène iapichino mélanie poké et even
substance berger vous font découvrir cet
ensemble rénové un mur construit pierre
par pierre et de nouvelles grilles sur
la place saint-pierre et dès l'entrée du
parc ou remarque un air de changement
après une année de travaux les plaisirs
aux as peuvent profiter de cet espace
entièrement réaménagé et réhabilité
selon sa structure d'origine
donc aujourd'hui on a un parent qui
ressemble à ce qu'il était au xviiie
siècle avec je dirais pas que c'est le
nôtre qui l'a dessinée mais ça ressemble
fortement à cela et on se retrouve avec
un fonds de parcours avant il y avait
une fuite est sauvage d'arbres plus ou
moins malade
maintenant avec un arc de cercle qui
accompagnait le cas d'al la statue qui
fait complètement miroir au château du
xviiie une place d'honneur pour une
statue mystérieuse de grande valeur
rénové au sein des ateliers tollis elle
a même été copié pour que son originale
soit conservé plus à l'abri l'objectif
faire de ce lieu devient espace encore
plus agréable dont les plaisirs wap ou
mme se saisir donc on a aujourd'hui je
dirais un complexe totale avec le parc
où nous avons implanté 2250 végétaux ce
qui est quand même je dirais assez
importants dont un verger qui sera
ouvert à la population ou nous
réintégreront nos ruches puisque nous
avons des ruches dans le parc du château
avec le petit square avec la place de
l'église
le mur qui est complètement refait la
stature mise en place et aujourd'hui on
ne commence déjà à réfléchir à la
réhabilitation du château un million et
demi d'euros ont été investis pour ces
travaux que la municipalité a financé
accompagné par l' agence des espaces
verts
de france le parc du château accueillera
le 8 juin prochain le festival escales
d'ailleurs dédié aux arts du monde qui
rassemble chaque année des mille
visiteurs la nouvelle invitée qui m'a
rejoint en plateau c'est le lieutenant
alexandre à pelletier blesse du
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
bonsoir alors vous êtes là commandant du
peloton autoroute de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines c'est l'un des
pelotons de l'escadron départemental de
sécurité routière edsr qui organise ce
dimanche son rallye technique et
pédagogique ça se passe ça ben c'est un
événement on peut le dire traditionnel
puisqu'il se déroule depuis plusieurs
années pourquoi organiser chaque année
alors s'est affaissé la septième édition
donc c'est organisé c'est le but et
pédagogique s'adresse aux motards pour
échanger avec eux sur les bonnes
pratiques en tant qu'usagers de la route
et leur faire découvrir à travers des
ateliers un parcours les subtilités de
la route il ya sûr on imagine comment
dire pardon je me perds c'est
sensibiliser vous l'avez dit sur les
dangers de la route sur l'accent
l'accidentalité dans les yvelines quelle
est la tendance aujourd'hui ça donc par
rapport aux motards c'est un public qui
est particulièrement vulnérables et qui
donc nécessite une attention
particulière s'agissant de
l'accidentalité depuis le début de
l'année il ya eu une cinquantaine
d'accidents et 18 ont concerné des
motards donc on a une attention
particulière à leur rencontre et on l'a
10 à organiser donc par le dsi requis et
l'escadron départemental de sécurité
routière dans les yvelines
il y a quatre pelotons c'est ça s'est
divisée en quatre pelotons de gendarmes
il ya quatre unités à la brigade
motorisée de beynes le peloton motorisé
de mantes-la-jolie la brigade motorisée
de rambouillet et le peloton autoroute
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et quelles
sont vos missions quel est le travail au
quotidien de l'escadron quatre missions
principales dans un premier temps c'est
la sécurité des accès et leur viabilité
s'assurer qu'aucun obstacle n'empêche
les usagers de circuler soit la neige ou
des accidents
ensuite on intervient évidemment sur les
accidents on peut assurer des escortes
de manifestations sportives ou de
secours on a une mission principale de
contrôle des flux donc contrôler tous
les usagers de la route quel qu'il soit
et quel que soit leur type de
déplacements professionnels ou autres
est une grosse mission de prévention
donc notamment à travers le rallye
motocycliste qui en est un exemple
et sur cette mission de prévention et
j'imagine un travail avec les
associations la sur cet événement vous
êtes en lien notamment avec la ffmc qui
est la fédération française des motards
en colère il ya ce travail avec le monde
associatif tout à fait donc notre
principal partenaire c'est le bureau
sécurité routière de la préfecture qu'un
acteur majeur avec le dsr dans
l'organisation du rallye motocycliste
mais il ya également les pompiers la
ffmc que vous venez de citer la
protection civile et nos camarades
policiers c'est un travail assez
partenariale finalement sur sur ce genre
de journées comment va se dérouler
justement cette journée quel est le
programme
alors il ya de temps il ya une première
partie accueil des participants et
présentation des différents ateliers et
du parcours qui
qui auront lieu en matinée et en après
midi donc il ya quatre ateliers au
travers desquelles ils pourront les
motards pourront découvrir la
maniabilité tester leur dextérité là le
secourisme leur sera présenté
l'intervention des pompiers sur un
accident de doha une simulation de
présentation et enfin une présentation
des équipements gendarmerie donc qui
nous servent à lutter contre
l'alcoolémie la vitesse les stupéfiants
et enfin dans un deuxième temps le
parcours qui a lieu sur route
encadré par un voire deux motocyclistes
professionnelle et qui leur permettra de
tester la trajectoire de sécurité et
malheureusement les inscriptions sont
déjà fermées ce que c'est on pouvait
s'inscrire à cet événement jusqu'au 15
avril je rappelle en tout cas que ce
rallye motocycliste est organisé par
l'escadron départemental de sécurité
routière c'est ce dimanche
ah ben je voulais profiter de votre
présence en plateau pour aborder très
rapidement un autre sujet celui du tour
de france 2010 9 la dernière étape sera
au départ de rambouillet le dimanche 28
juillet la grande boucle qui passera par
le territoire des yvelines sas est
assuré jusqu'en 2023
comment ça se prépare du côté du
groupement de gendarmerie des yvelines
quel dispositif sera mis en place quels
seront vos missions sur sur ce jour
d'étape du tour de france donc il ya
deux volets un premier volet statique
qui consiste pour la gendarmerie a
assuré la sécurité de l'axé interdire
l'accès aux automobilistes lors du
passage des coureurs et un volet
dynamique où là les motards précède les
différentes entités qui traverseront le
qui emprunteront le parcours et les
moteurs s'assure que l'accès est libre
s'agissant des entités accompagner ces
divers et variés il ya le groupe espoir
du cyclisme
la caravane publicitaire bien évidemment
et enfin les coureurs que ce soit en
peloton en échappée ou retardataires
mais je rappelle que cette étape c'est
le dimanche 28 juillet ce sera au départ
de rambouillet direction est les
champs-elysées merci à lieutenant
alexandre at alexandra pelletier blaise
d'être passé en plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes la commandante du peloton
autoroute de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
petit tour à présent dans nos salles de
cinéma saint quentinois si vous en avez
l'habitude le mercredi ce soit on
retrouve del pino de retour du festival
de cannes la programmation du grenier à
sel de trappes c'est au micro de michael
et demi d'euros dans notre salle au
grenier à sel cette semaine nous vous
proposons pas un coup de coeur mais cinq
coups de coeur le premier film c'est un
nein tease
c'est ça se passe dans les années 90 à
los angeles et on suit un jeune un jeune
garçon de 13 ans qui
qui vient pas une révolution intérieure
qui découvre le skate et la rébellion
et c'est un très beau film à l'ancienne
que je vous conseille très fortement
seas un peu c'est vraiment notre coup de
coeur en grenier à sel
nous avons aussi dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'environnement
le grain et l'ivraie c'est un
documentaire argentin sur le mode
d'agriculture en argentine et toutes les
conséquences néfastes que ça peut avoir
donc c'est le grain et l'ivraie nous
vous proposons aussi pour le jeune
public pour les enfants à partir de 6
ans royal corgis est un film d'animation
belge
avec les chiens de la reine d'angleterre
et de son chien préféré être
se retrouvent à la rue et il va tout
faire pour retrouver à la maison et en
chemin il va rencontrer l'amour ça
s'appelle royal corps lee nous avons
aussi gloria belle avec julianne moore
et john turturro ou
le personnage génial bora est
célibataire cinquantenaire et
et elle profite de la vie elle rencontre
elle rencontre le personnage de jeunes
tourtereaux dans la
dans une boîte de nuit et elle
redécouvre alors on découvre un peu la
vie le dernier film de la semaine c'est
les crevettes wright est une comédie
française sur un club de water-polo
huguet qui va faire les championnats du
monde en europe et où les suisses et c
c'est très attrayant c'est très très fou
et on aime beaucoup ça donc les crocs et
de maïté vous retrouver tout ça sur
notre site internet cinéma grenier à sel
point com et puis vous connaissez sans
doute le musée lambinet à versailles
avant d'être ce musée lambinet c'est une
famille une famille d'artistes de
collectionneurs et de passionnés le site
a décidé de lui rendre hommage à
l'occasion du 90e anniversaire de
donation à l'hôtel de ville mélanie
poker nathalie lambiner laden est un
propriétaire de l'hôtel
celle qui sait de la maison familiale à
la ville de versailles à sa mort en 1926
à la condition d'en faire un musée
elle avait souhaité garder un souvenir
dans ce lieu important pour elle ces
lieux doit elle était heureuse avec son
fils mort prématurément et elle explique
dans son testament qu'elle souhaite
faire donc dieu l'hôtel en billets un
musée pour la ville de versailles et
elle va jusqu'à indiquer les horaires
d'ouverture les jours de fermeture
qu'elle a recruté un conservateur les
lambiner les descendants de tailleur de
marchands de vêtements passionné d'art
leur collection est estimée entre 300 et
500 pièces un goût typique de la belle
époque dont une grande partie des
oeuvres a été dispersée
de cette famille passionnée salle est
accordée à aimer lambiner l'artiste
soutenu par son oncle maire de
versailles
il devient le disciple de jean baptiste
camille corot et est devenu peintre de
paysages historique
un genre qui est écrit en 1817 et
progressivement il va en fait commencé à
travailler en plein air puisque corps au
conseil c'est différent disciples emule
de faire confiance en fait alors
impression première de rester sensible à
la nature sans oublier toujours de
retourner travailler en atelier devenu
musée en 1932 l'hôtel rassemble
aujourd'hui des pièces des collections
de lambiner et de la bibliothèque
municipale de la commune pour devenir le
musée d'art de la cité royale
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 je vous rappelle ce rendez vous dans
un instant un 7,8 débat à spécial sur
les résultats des élections européennes
c'est avec aurélie ronze belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]